for me what's worked really well is that
signify we have a really Niche laser
focus on a back-end programming language
called Scala the reason why we chose to
focus on scholar was because it's hard
to find there is a lot of customers that
look for that skill set and these people
aren't readily available they're not
really camped out on job boards you
really have to go deep into you know
searches events meetups to find these
people the amount of customers that
we've got into because we focus on
scalar is incredible and I think that's
you know something that maybe businesses
should focus on you know what's going to
be your in to get into these companies
what's the thing that makes you
different
thank you